first of all they were cold just around
four o'clock in the morning two ilsen
road to the west of the city center
where they say they find two people dead
in the street they were then called
about a mile to the east to Milton
Street where they say a driver had
attempted to run over three people those
three people we understand are in
hospital and then at some point it's not
clear exactly when but a man was found
dead on magdala road again about a mile
or so to the north and we also
understand that the 31 year old man was
arrested here on Ben Tink Road and you
can see a picture and I of the van that
police have recovered which appears to
have some significant damage to the
windscreen and forensics officers are
currently coming through the area now if
we just pull back out onto the map I
want to give you a sense of the scale of
the police operation we've plotted all
of the streets and the roads that police
closed at some point throughout the
morning and you can see there the Shaded
area in all very roughly it's about a
square mile of the center of Nottingham
now not all of that was was closed
clearly but if we pinch in slightly on
the city center you can see there made
Marion Way a major dual carriageway is
the white box to the left to the right
is uh Milton Street where the van ran
over three people and this is a picture
of Milton Street and you can see this is
a major thoroughfare full of shops and
bus lanes and the like that was
essentially locked down for several
hours through most of the morning this
morning essentially during rush hour on
a busy Tuesday morning